co-founder Jonah I became really
fascinated by the idea of allowing
people to see the world through other
people's eyes right now and it was born
through I I had a trip to Istanbul in
late 2013 and the Taksim Square protests
were happening in gazi Park and I
remember thinking to myself he knows
it's safe for me to go there because I
was planning on traveling to Istanbul
but I really wanted to see was a a
picture or a live feed of what it looked
like on the street that my hotel was on
it and what it made us realize this
wouldn't it be amazing to essentially
like have this teleportation device that
would allow us to see what was happening
anywhere through someone's eyes and it's
had an amazing take off it's been very
popular but where do you see its future
it's been very popular with some of my
colleagues for example is it going to
replace broadcast news I don't I don't
see it as replacing broadcast news I see
it as as very much complementing
broadcast news some of the best
storytellers there are our
correspondents such as you know skies
skies very own mark stone and and these
folks are trained to tell stories in
very powerful ways and they
traditionally have done so through the
written medium on television but now
with mobile devices you can tell stories
and attract an audience through mobile
devices and get people where they are in
their pockets and so I think that's what
really compels me about the feature of
news and journalism through periscope
there's lots of other use cases that I
think make periscope charming whether
you're you know watching Roger Federer
walk on the grounds of Wimbledon
from his practice court to no centre
court as he showed us last week or
whether you're watching your nephews
first footsteps you know and have your
family and friends watching along that I
think is the power of periscope because
it takes you there and to say you know
stepping into someone's shoes and not
just experiencing it live but also
interacting with the broadcaster that
makes that's what makes periscope
different than television is the viewers
can say something and two seconds later
you know the question they ask gets
answered and that that interactivity is
what makes periscope special I think
have you got the right partnership and
platform paulus though because you know
you talk with interactivity there surely
you be better off with Facebook and
Twitter well no I mean I think about the
thing about Twitter is Twitter is the
the definitive source of live I think of
even before my company was acquired by
Twitter I mean when there's an
earthquake or
I hear a loud like I was in San
Francisco I remember very distinctly
four years ago I was in my old office
and I heard this loud bang it sounded
like an explosion and instinctively what
I did is I searched San Francisco
explosion and I think that's how you ask
a lot of people what Twitter is and
maybe they give you different answers
but that's the one thing people realize
about Twitter is it is the source of
life it is giving you a pulse of what's
happening around the world right now and
the funny thing is that's what periscope
is just through live video rather than
140 characters and that's why the
marriage between you know Twitter and
periscope I think makes a ton of sense
how do you keep it fresh because we've
seen you know post cope has had a rapid
ascent
you've left meerkat in the dust how do
you prevent periscope becoming the next
meerkat we have to innovate we have to
keep building things that people love to
use and that's why I think we're in a
really good place to do that because
we're so passionate about our vision of
what we want to do and also we like to
sort of philosophically be in a constant
state of disappointment around what
we've built because that's what
motivates us to keep making it better so
whether that's adding features or making
the features we already have better or
creating new discovery tools like we
added with we added a map feature that
the open periscope you can zoom in
anywhere in the world literally you can
zoom into Brazil and see all the
broadcaster lives a little red dots on
the map and you can click on them and
see what's happening right there that
that is a really powerful discovery tool
you know imagine the next time there are
protests in Baltimore there's an
earthquake in Nepal or a celebration in
San Francisco you can zoom in and
literally discover a place live so we
just need to keep innovating and adding
features like that and if we do I think
that's how we keep periscope fresh I
came back well it's been great talk to
you thank you so much for joining us and
sky news tonight